we're not just looking for a time
criminal we're looking for a loki a
variation of
this guy in the disney plus series loki
the god of mischief is arrested for time
crimes
guilty of a crime against the sacred
timeline absolutely not you have the
wrong person this confirms there's a
multiverse in the marvel cinematic
universe
an idea that's been teased in previous
movies the next doctor strange movie is
even called the
multiverse of madness but are there real
scientific theories behind this
fictional multiverse
i'm professor michio kaku professor of
theoretical physics
let's break down the marvel multiverse
in the first episode of the series loki
goes to time
jail and is subjected to this adorable
cartoon orientation video
timelines battled each other for
supremacy
but then the all-knowing timekeepers
emerged
bringing peace by reorganizing the
multiverse into a sacred
timeline when you watch this clip you
say to yourself
ah come on i mean this is just a cartoon
it's science fiction
but believe it or not elements of that
are actually encoded in the laws of
physics
we do believe that at the beginning of
time there was chaos
all these world lines colliding quantum
fluctuations taking place everywhere
and out of that came our classical world
our newtonian world isaac newton said
that time is like an arrow it fires in
one direction
never deviates einstein comes along and
says no
the timeline is not an arrow it's a
river
a river that can speed up and slow down
the quantum theory says the river of
time can fork
into many rivers to create parallel
realities we branch off continually
every time we make a motion every time
we move
there could be a universe where you have
a twin brother or a twin sister
another universe where you could be a
billionaire another universe where you
could be
a mass murderer and believe it or not
you can calculate that number using
quantum mechanics
all we physicists can do is calculate
the probabilities
that these universes can exist but our
universe
the so-called sacred timeline is the
common sense universe
the universe of newton it is the
dominant timeline
which is singled out in marvel comics
according to marvel comics
a few of these variants that dva from
our timeline
can really mess things up and create
another
big bang of some sort where these
multiverses collide
right but does the multiverse really
look like a bunch of squiggly lines
they're two ways of visualizing the
multiverse one way is to look at this
long timeline where we have the past
the present and the future and like a
tree
branches keep coming off there's another
way of looking at it einstein says that
our universe is a bubble
expanding that peels off a baby bubble
or perhaps two bubbles
collide giving you a bigger bubble and
we think that is
the big bang most of these bubbles pop
into existence and pop right back
into the vacuum never to be seen again
and so the vacuum that is a state of
nothingness is
teaming with bubble universes being
created and destroyed
and that's why stephen hawking called it
the space-time
foam out of this space-time foam the
chaos of all these different timelines
one bubble just kept on going and that
is
our universe or in the marvel language
the sacred timeline
the newtonian world that we see around
us all right so
surprisingly marvel's cinematic universe
and contemporary physics theories seem
to align here
but where do they deviate it deviates on
the question of the tva
on behalf of the time variance authority
i hereby arrest you for crimes against
the sacred timeline
the tva are time cops they are the time
variants authorities
they pick out variants who will create
their own timeline
which will gum up the works and create a
collision between
multiverses well to the best of
knowledge there is
no tva we are from the future right
what is the tva i mean it's from the
future it sounds from the future pretty
futurey
right so what about time travel then
there's a lot of time
travel happening in loki and in the
marvel movies is it even possible
i have no idea but we're talking about
time travel here either it's all a joke
or none of it is
according to einstein's general theory
of relativity time travel
is possible we're good and in fact now
we have scores of solutions of
einstein's equations
which allow for time travel so this is
an active area
of theoretical research the quantum
theory
resolves the whole paradox question of
what happens if you alter the past
to make the future impossible the answer
is
you simply alter somebody else's
universe
if you go backwards in time to save
abraham lincoln
from being assassinated at the ford
theater
you saved somebody else's abraham
lincoln who looks just like
your abraham lincoln but your lincoln
died your timeline is not altered
you've altered somebody else's timeline
because the river of time has
forked into two rivers so
marvel is taking some liberties with the
physics of time travel
let's take a step back and see how the
multiverse idea
was first introduced early on in the mcu
everything is connected
all nine realms all nine realms are
passing through each other
and gravity light and even matter is
crashing from one world to the other
when you first see this scene out of the
thor movies you say to yourself ah come
on give me a break
this is just gobbled the from some
hollywood scriptwriter's imagination but
actually there's some physical basis to
reality in what he said in thor comics
we have the nine realms
nine universes in physics we have
nine spatial dimensions and one time
dimension
and so having nine realms in thor would
correspond to the nine dimensions of
space
in string theory according to marvel
comics one dimension has the earth on it
and another dimension has asgard and
what connects the two
is the bifrost bridge it's a tunnel
connecting
parallel universes it is the
einstein-rosen bridge
in 1935 albert einstein wrote a paper
with his student
nathan rosen connecting two black holes
together
a black hole is like a funnel you take
one funnel take the other funnel upside
down
join them together and then you have a
bridge
connecting two parallel universes any
questions yeah
can i have my shoe back in spider-man
far from home
mysterio lies about being from another
universe there are multiple realities
peter
this is earth dimension 616. you're
saying there's a multiverse but peter's
mind is blown
if you read spider-man comics you know
that peter parker is a nerd
his true love is science and he uses
science to defeat his enemies
completely changes how we understand the
initial singularity we're talking about
an internal inflation system and how
does that even work with all the quantum
eternal inflation that's an actual
theory in cosmology
the theory basically says that big bangs
happen all the time
even as we are speaking multiverses are
being created
that's called internal inflation
inflation is basically the creation of a
baby universe but these baby universes
are being created
all the time in this bubble bath of
universes each universe is perhaps
with the laws of physics slightly
altered with the flow of time slightly
different
you can go to any physics conference
where we have nobel laureates
directors of major laboratories talking
about cosmology
and they'll say that yes eternal
inflation this multiverse idea
is the dominant theory in cosmology
today
this universe is only one of an infinite
number
you can't talk about the marvel
multiverse without mentioning the
sorcerer's supreme
and here we have doctor strange hurled
through the looking glass
hurled through the einstein-rosen bridge
to another reality
could different universes actually look
like this
would the laws of physics be so
different the debate among physicists
today
is can the laws of physics actually
change in another baby universe stephen
hawking thought so
which means that our familiar universe
our benevolent universe that we know and
love
may have different laws if you go
through a wormhole to a different
universe
dark universes universes of chaos
of universes where there's only darkness
no stars
only blackness stars do not ignite in
these other universes
life as we know it cannot exist only
the chaos of ramdenness exists in these
other universes is that possible
and the answer is yes that's a scary
thought
but with new loki episodes plus the
doctor strange sequel coming soon
viewers will have the multiverse on
their mind for the foreseeable future
young people know it's science fiction
for the most part
perhaps based on ideas from physics
and as a consequence they may decide to
make a career out of it
and become a physicist that's how i got
started so it helps to have
young people being thrilled by some of
the ideas coming from science
because they know in the back of the
mind yes it is science fiction after all
but maybe just maybe there's a reality
that they can partake of
you